hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar deep learning in optics my name
is Laura banter Dilla from the
california nanosystems Institute at UCLA
where we perform some of the work which
is going to be presented today and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational webinar is presented
by lab roots and brought to you by like
Microsystems
to learn more please visit like a-- -
Microsystems dot-com so let's get
started you can post questions to the
speaker at the original presentation
while you're fresh in your mind to do so
please simply tap them into the drop
down box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge a side window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you do
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the ask a question box located at the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar which offers free
continuing education credits so please
click on the continuing education credit
tab located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credit
I now presents to the speakers professor
a Dogen askin professor and Yarra River
son and graduate student Hong da Huang
from the electrical engineering
department at UCLA for a complete
biography of our speakers please visit
biography time at the top of your screen
professor Erskine you may now begin your
presentation
thank you thanks Lauren so hello
everyone
it's my great pleasure to introduce our
team and our work on deep learning in
optics to you so basically this is going
to be a presentation doing by three of
us myself our graduate students Hong
Dhawan and our junior faculty here
Rivington
so before I dive into the topic of today
I'd like to give you a some brief
introduction to our lab we work on
computational imaging and sensing with
applications in biomedical space
point-of-care Diagnostics mobile health
telemedicine and more and more recently
environmental monitoring a key element
in our research has been the use of
smartphones and smartphone components
for essentially creating mobile and
cost-effective interfaces
this line of research has come a long
way maybe more than 10 years ago with a
smartphone based microscope we could
barely see red blood cells but these
days actually you can utilize a mobile
phone-based microscope in a
cost-effective manner to even see
individual DNA molecules and size them
with up to about a kilo base pair sizing
actress as shown here with a simple
inexpensive interface you can see
florescent intact DNA molecules in size
them with about one kilo base sizing
accuracy and this is actually quite
relevant for bringing genetic testing to
to these types of microscopes in a
recent work we've performed targeted DNA
sequencing and in situ mutation analysis
using a multi modal mobile phone based
microscope which had right field in
addition to two different channels of
fluorescence where each fluorescent
channel was used to look into amplified
signals coming from a tissue to reveal
mutant and wild type genetic sequencing
happening through rolling circle circle
circle amplification a process that
amplifies DNA from a
pamphlet and essentially creates a
cluster of a DNA that's labeled and
imaged by the smartphone based
microscope these are some highlights
about how we can utilize smartphones and
smartphone based components for
microscopy and for sensing and in this
slide I'm sharing with you some of the
examples from our lab for the
utilization of the smartphone as a
sensor for waterborne pathogens for
heavy metals quantification of different
kinds of diagnostic tests these are now
enabled through smartphone based
interfaces and in a nutshell essentially
this line of research is aiming to
democratize advanced measurement tools
by making them cost-effective and
compact while at the same time we're
providing the same level of specificity
and sensitivity and resolution that you
need that you expect from lab grade
instrumentation after this brief intro
I'd like to come to essentially the
topic of today which is how we're using
deep neural nets for image formation
image reconstruction and image
transformation if you look at today's
symbiotic relationship between
professionals and and machine learning
we see some very uh interesting and
symbiotic relationship in the sense that
especially machine learning techniques
are being used at the front end to help
diagnosticians
see through many different images using
statistical learning so helping
essentially diagnosed issues and
professionals to deal with an
exponential growth in the images to be
diagnosed and we've seen the impact of
deep learning in this in this field
tremendously whether it's actually
detection of cancer detection of tumor
margins a grading of tumors and looking
into segmentation and a detection of
different kinds of features within
different medical images these are some
of the examples of how deep neural nets
and deep learning in general have been
utilized to help diagnostic analysis of
various different medic
today though I'd like to emphasize
another very exciting opportunity on the
use of deep neural Nets and that's
actually exactly highlighting this this
new opportunity which is enhancing the
image is coming from microscopic tools
by improving them by creating new kinds
of image transformations image
reconstruction methods powered by deep
learning
and today I'll share with you some of
these examples of how we're enriching
microscopy experience through deep
neural nets and I'll start before I pass
it to Hongdae in the air to present
other results on this I'd like to give
you some examples on how machine
learning is helping us in polarography
in holographic image reconstruction in a
nutshell we're migrating from physics
based reconstruction methods to
data-driven image data-driven
reconstruction methods so in this
example that I'll share with you we're
going to teach a neural net some physics
through image data help the neural net
essentially soul holographic microscopy
imaging problem inverse problem so in
holography one of the most important
things is actually phase retrieval a
hologram encodes the information of the
sample in interference patterns as shown
here for example and you need phase to
reconstruct this this sample only after
phase Reche really could actually go
back to the sample plane and reveal from
these Holograms shown here to what you
would like to see the subcellular
features of in this case a tissue sample
over the last several decades there is
different research groups utilize
physics physical insights to create
different types of phase Reggie will add
whole graphic reconstruction methods
open times in involving different types
of measurements where you would for
example change the angle of illumination
wavelength of illumination or for
example sample the sensor to encode more
information in you
Recordings in your Holograms to be
reconstructed physically to go from a
hologram is shown here for example into
a nice phase relief reconstruction so
that we spend a lot of time as a
community to mature this field so that
we can reconstruct images without any
artifacts or with least artifacts using
physical techniques physical methods
deep neural nets are now changing this
game for us we like deep neural nets for
inverse problems in general because yes
it takes a while to train them it can be
a few hours to baby up to a day even
longer sometimes to train a neural net
but once it's trained it's fixed and
it's a single feed-forward without any
iterations and this actually a
game-changer for us because a lot of
physical reconstructions in holography
and other inverse problem problems that
the computational imaging field has been
tackling there are always iterations
between your guesses and what you want
to reconstruct and this is not changing
the game because deep neural Nets can
actually solve various different
optimization problems in a single
feed-forward very efficiently and wrap
it this is essentially what we are using
through image data through a holographic
image data to teach the neural net to do
this physical transformation in this
example we are looking at inline
holography where the sample goes in
front of a CMOS imager typically
submillimetre gap between the sample the
sensor and we record inline Holograms of
the sample only after phase retrieval
you'll be able to see the specimen as
shown here these are pet sameer samples
that we're trying to reconstruct in this
case a convolutional neural net has been
trained with pairs of images are
typically close to 10,000 patches of
input and output images are used to
train a neural net like this where at
the end the Newlands actually learns to
transform a reconstruction that doesn't
have any phase information into every
construction that has the
recovered image of the Ampligen phase
information of the specimen which is
essentially uh creating an alternative
path to physics based reconstruction
methods in fact the neural net was
trained with the gold standard physical
method to get the ground truth image
during its training this training can
take as I said more than 12 hours
depending on the the type of the sample
that you want to reconstruct with once
it's trained it's actually a fairly
robust and it gives you the same kind of
reconstruction as you expect from a
physical reconstruction what you see
here is a comparison of the network's
output in a blind inference the sample
has been never seen by the network and
how it compares to physical
reconstruction one that's very exciting
here is that some of the artifacts that
are coming from the temporal and spatial
coherence of the illumination are
mitigated in the network as well which
is a very unique feature of these
network based solutions in the sense
that it's a transformation from an input
a holographic field to a clean artifact
free to image artifact free phase
rectifier construction it's a plane to
plane mapping in this case and any of
those dust particles or other particles
are actually washed away at the
reconstruction in the next example I'm
showing you the same type of a result
with a tissue sample this is a breast
tissue section where the network input
is shown here on the left the network
off is shown in the middle and a
physical reconstruction giving you
exactly the same thing with eight
different hologram acquisition is shown
on the right which which shows you the
success of the neural map in a single
inferior
in terms of savings or obviously we have
also savings in image acquisition
hologram acquisition and reconstruction
time what you see here is a comparison
of a physical reconstruction method
which uses multiple Heights for example
if you use three different heights
sample percentage of distances the
reconstruction takes about 28 seconds
for a certain field of view about a
millimeter square if you use for example
five Heights five different sample the
sensor distances it's about 35 seconds
then our neural net actually is fairly
fast and saving time because of the non
intuitive nature of its route inference
at the same time it's also reducing the
number of image acquisition steps so
next I'll share with you some additional
things that you can teach a neural net
to do some more exotic things in this
example we're going to do not only phase
retrieval and holographic game into
construction but also do auto focusing
so the neural lab will be trained here
by the focused holograms where the
ground truth will be individually
focused by a physical or two focusing
mechanism and at the end of this
training process the neural net is
actually going to bring various
different parts of a three-dimensional
sample into focus and at the same time
phase rate creep eliminating to image
and other artifacts of coherent imaging
a good example of this is shown here for
imaging a 3d distribution of via
aerosols these are particles captured
from air that have different heights if
we take a physics based reconstruction
which is shown here in B as you scan
through the sample volume at different
heights
you'll be seeing different particles
coming into focus for example if you
move from minus 10 micron height to plus
ten nice and high some particles get out
of focus some particles get into focus
whereas in the network that is trained
with the focus holograms you see that
the inference actually brings all of
these particles that are 3d distributed
into focus at the same time so we have
an extended depth of field within which
we can bring individual particles into
focus while also relieving their face
which is actually quite interesting in
the sense that it doesn't satisfy the
Maxwell's equations we expand the depth
of field and this depth of field
improvement is also shown in in Part C
for a single particle as you move the
particle to different heights you see
natural defocusing as a result of the
wave spreading but in in the network
results it's actually in focus over a
plus/minus hundred microns which is the
range that it was trained for the
network was trained within plus minus
0.1 millimeter this also works for
tissue samples it's shown here this is a
connective tissue sample the neural
networks very nicely over 0.1 millimeter
in one direction where it's standard
physics basic instructions quickly get
out of focus as you can focus the sample
so these are not just cool results in
the sense that they're helping us
provide alternative methods for
reconstructing Holograms in fact we are
using them in different kinds of mobile
instrumentation for example recently
we've created an imaging flow cytometer
that can look into flowing objects with
a beautiful resolution in red green and
blue and synthesize colorful images of
these floating objects this is powered
by deep neural net based holder
constructions another device was looking
into bio aerosols and sensing pollen and
mold particles without the use for of
any labels it's a label free by aerosol
detection system this is also powered by
the extended depth of field and whole
graph reconstruction created by deep
neural nets and recently it also
utilized the same framework for sensing
of viruses using lensless holographic
microscopy techniques in other words
these intervention these kinds of ideas
are helping us enable high-throughput
screening high-throughput imaging
sensing devices
to look at extremely large volumes of
sample air water or Butler fluids even
in field settings and that's where we're
utilizing Nuala to get these mobile
devices even more powerful what's very
exciting about this framework is that it
actually also transform images from one
modality to another one this is
something that Honda and Yuri will
emphasize more with various other
biomedical applications but I'll finish
up my part of the presentation by
telling you how you can actually train a
neural net to take a holographic
reconstruction and transform it into an
image that's other the color and image
contrast of bright field microscopy in
terms of the transformation here we're
trading a neural net based on holograms
and the ground truth is coming from a
scanning bright field optical microscope
so we're actually having best of both
worlds 3d scanning capability of
holography digitally and the beautiful
color and image contrast of incoherent
bright field microscopy and the results
are summarized here for some examples
these are Poland particles Holograms are
shown here
if you back propagate these Holograms to
different heights you see artifacts of
coherence just like an inline holography
the neural net takes these and
reconstructs the same color and spatial
contrast a feature contrasts a bright
field microscopy as if it was skin in 3d
with a bright field optical microscope
eliminating all these artifacts but also
bringing the contrast mechanism of
bright field microscopy and this is
obviously a very advantageous because we
can take a whole of am back propagated
digitally to different heights and at
each height get the corresponding bright
field image coming from a high na
objective webb's hole through virtual
transformations enable by deep learning
and this is actually indeed quite
powerful in what it can achieve and in
the next part of this presentation HMDA
is going to talk to you about how these
cost modality image transformations help
us achieve super resolution help us for
example
transform a confocal microscopy image
into sted microscopy equivalent images
and and many other possibilities so now
I'll pass it to home duck for this part
of the presentation conga thank you I'm
home Dawa I'm a graduate student at the
UCLA so next I'm going to share with you
our recent progress in cross modality
image transformation that achieves super
resolution in fluorescence microscopy so
to begin with we first show you three
major resolution techniques these are
stimulated emission depletion microscopy
structured illumination microscopy and
localization microscopy so these
techniques provide unprecedented access
to the inner working of cells and
various biological process however these
techniques often rely on sophisticated
optical setups and extensive
computational processing of the image
data in fact involves dr. basic talks
there is a summary of the current
techniques so in order to acquire super
result images the sted and the
localization microscopy techniques
require much more photons
somewhere between hundreds to hundreds
of thousand fold the structured
illumination microscopy does not require
that much photons but needs multiple
exposures and the computational
reconstruction
so here we present a deep learning based
framework to achieve super resolution
and cross modality image transformation
in fluorescence microscopy we
demonstrate a possible method for
high-throughput microscopy and the
potential to democratize supe resolution
microscopy two more researchers in our
matter between the neural network model
we can transform a low resolution image
into a high resolution one a master is
purely data-driven which means it does
not rely on any prior knowledge or
modeling of the imaging process
furthermore we also show that a neural
network inferred image has extended
steps of focus and improve
signal-to-noise ratio
so how do we fin a neural network first
we start with the generator Network
model it takes a low resolution image
and enhance the resolution we then
compare this network enhanced image
against the high resolution image
acquired by another modality and
calculate a pixel weight loss in this
work we used min square error and
structural similarity index this is the
first part of our network loss then we
have another discriminators network
model that tries to distinguish the
network enhanced image and the true
ground truth image and gives us the
water real loss this is the second part
of the loss so during the network
cleaning the generator tries to flow
this discriminator network and the
discriminator tries to distinguish the
two images when they are in an
equilibrium State
the network is conversed so we have a
generator model screen that can take the
low resolution image and enhance it to
match the resolution high resolution
image we have to emphasize that the
accurate registration of the low
resolution and high resolution images
it's critical to the performance of our
network model
so we first demonstrate the resolution
improvement with wide field fluorescence
images you can see here on the left is
the network input image captured with
the 10x objective lens on the right you
can see the ground truth images that is
captured with 20x objectives the green
colored microtubules and the magenta
colored effective unknown as set of
skeleton filaments that keeps the cell
shape the network output images reveal
the fine structures and agree very well
with the ground crews images we also
noticed that our network inferred image
has extended depth of field we can see
in this slide here is a most blood
vessel that grows out of the plane if
you look at the network output although
it's a 3d structure everything is in
focus
this is highlighted by the green and
yellow arrows pointed readers you can
further confirm this effect which I
extended depth of field image that is
synthesized from a-z stack of 34 images
you can also apply this framework to
convoke Oh images and super resolve them
to match the resolution of stab
microscopy here these images show 20
nanometer fluorescence nanoparticles
some of them are closely spaced that
cannot be resolved by the confocal
microscope I work the neural network can
successfully resolve them and the
message the ground truth images we also
draw cross sections to confirm this
agreement as I commonly used a method to
quantify the resolution in soup
resolution microscopy we characterize
the applied stress functions here we
selected more than 400 individual
nanoparticles at the same locations in
confocal stat and a network influenced
images we feed the individual
nanoparticles with Gaussian profile and
calculated their full width half maximum
distributions as shown on the right side
the fullest half maximum of confocal
microscope is centered at around 290
nanometer roughly corresponding to a
diffraction limited imaging system where
the fullest has maximum distribution of
the network of the images and the steady
images are a third one 110 nanometer
this beautiful shift of PSF distribution
clearly indicates the resolution
improvement furthermore the network
output image also has improved
signal-to-noise ratio compared to the
input and grams of the image as shown by
example of confocal to study image
transformation here and we actually
believe this is one of the major reasons
that the network can Deacon walk the
input image with higher signal-to-noise
ratio
we can also estimate the local points
read functions you can see that we
decouple the network output image with
regarding to the network input image and
show the PSF of local regions we repeat
the same operations with Grand Cross
image and input images we see that the
network can actually learn the specialty
very point thread functions and perform
an adaptive deconvolution to super
reaches of the nano particles the next
we can also apply this combo code to
stat image transformation framework to
super result hist of three distributions
within fixed HeLa cell nuclei you can
see here the network input output and
ground truth images shows that the
networker successfully improved the
resolution of a confocal microscope
image mentioned the third image of the
same nuclei we draw the green and the
yellow cross-section profiles to confirm
this agreement next we sign off straight
across modality image transformation
framework by transforming
diffraction-limited
twelve images to match the troughs in
reconstruction curve means total
internal reflection fluorescence
microscopy well curve C means curve with
structured illumination this thing on
the left is called clustering coated pit
it is one of the mechanisms that the
cell bring different car goes inside the
cells so they form these dog shapes
inside the plasma membrane and the car
box is inserted or we are doing curve we
only illuminate the parts that are very
close to the plasma so they appear as
ring
these two
OTPs how they're all dynamics for
example they associate with acting and
they also spin off kids
however these structures are so small
that cannot be resolved by
diffraction-limited method as you can
see here in the curve images as the
network input we imaged the sum1 15s
cells that expressing gfp labelled
cluttering adapter a p2 to highlight the
examples the neural networks was able to
detect the the association of
clathrin-coated pits from larger
clustering plaque as shown on the bottom
row it can also detect development of
culture bearing clustering cages as
shown in the middle row the there are
three kids here um in fact this
framework is so robust that we actually
applied it to a video of the clustering
dynamics and these are the significant
frames that we cropped from the videos
so common concern of computational
approaches to enhance image resolution
is the potential special artifact here
we use the nano base square of login
which is a tool box to quantify the
potential artifacts for super resolution
microscopy between a low resolution
image and the super result image we
calculated the error between network of
the image against the input low
resolution image as shown here the
resolution scaled Pearson correlation is
almost 1 and the resolution skilled
error is point nine out of 255 which
means a high degree of agreement of the
network enhanced image and the network
input image to understand the scale of
this error we also calculated the ground
troops image against the network input
image in fact the graph shows image has
larger error and lower Pearson
correlation coefficient we think this is
partially from the limited depth of
field of the high a objective to do a
more intuitive comparison we also
overlay the network in half the image
and the graphical image in different
color channels if there is any mismatch
or artifacts we should be able to see a
color block there however we see that is
a uniform white colored image that
indicates the high degree of agreement
another way to look at this result is to
do a spatial frequency analyzation here
we look at the spatial frequency
spectrum the cross sections of the radio
D outreach power spectrum confirms the
success of the network output matching
the extended spatial frequency spectrum
from a higher resolution imaging system
so conceptually the network is
performing a knowledge-based frequency
spectrum ex-police extrapolation
next we demonstrate the generalization
ability of our network to enhance the
image resolution of objects that it has
never seen before on the left you see a
network model that is trained with
microtubules of a cell and outside to
aspect in melanoma cells and the most
keenly if super resolve them and the
match really well with the ground truth
images on the right is the network model
that is trained with affecting images
and then applied to mitochondria blood
vessel and mas kidney they also make
very well with the ground truth images
in fact the extended depth of field
images will show you previously
it's a most blood vessel and it's a new
kind of sample that the network has
never seen before it's still on generate
our InFocus high resolution image
we also checked the generalization
capability without curve to curve seam
transformation framework or network
model was trimmed with as um glass 15 SL
and here we applied to Drosophila embryo
tissues it clearly resolved these
fluorescent particles and agrees very
well with the Graham suit images these
frames are also cropped from video that
shows very robust framework capability
however we have to emphasize that
whenever possible an optimal model
should be screened for new imaging
modalities here we show that by using a
model trained with Texas red filter and
affecting images it can improve the
resolution of the turf images and cabaco
images however the image quality cannot
match the optimal model inference this
does not mean the network does not have
generalization capabilities it still
improves images and it's a further
question to quantify how far we can push
a existing network model to infer new
images so in summary we presented a deep
learning based cross modalities of
resolution framework that takes a single
image as input and transform it with the
iterative process the success of our
master is demonstrated by low to high a
wide field microscopic image
confirmation confer go to style
microscopic image transformation and
curve 213 microscopic image
transformation this purely data-driven
approach does not need any prior
knowledge of the image transformation
model we also saw that the network
inferred image has extended depth of
field and improved signal-to-noise ratio
and at last we show that a virtual
network model can generalize to new
types of samples it has never seen
before
so here we demonstrated cross modality
transformation
from a low resolution to the resonance
image to a high resolution from
fluorescence image taken by the more
sophisticated set up next we'll also
demonstrate cross modality
transformation from auto fluorescence
images to the equivalence of Bradfield
images which will be brought to you by
dr. ribbon sir thank you thank you home
done and hi my name is Gary Robinson I'm
a junior faculty in the electrical
computer engineering department in UCLA
and you know we're going to talk about
how the burning can do a very
interesting task or than translational
task of virtual staining of label free
tissue sections for histopathology in a
nutshell
histopathology is the diagnosis and
study of diseases of the tissues and
sense of decades and hundreds of years
ago it's being used to look at cells
application and tissue structures under
a microscope the basic process goes as
follows a patient will after some sort
of the screening process will undergo a
biopsy and then that biopsy will be a
fixed and sectioned into small tissues
which will be examined under the
microscope unfortunately if you would
look at the tissues as they are in their
native form under a broad field
microscope you'll see a very poor
contrast which doesn't provide any
clinical information at that point
that's about 150 years ago or so
scholars have devised all kinds of
techniques of staining the tissues basic
we're utilizing the chemical environment
the subsolar chemical environment to
bind specific chromophores to the tissue
section and provide a contrast that can
be used for diagnosis which since then
has been the gold standard in numerous
types of diseases and specifically
cancer so histochemical staining has a
few drawbacks first of all it's a
laborious process it is a time-consuming
especially to go to more of a special
stain it's an expensive process which
requires multiple chemical reagents it
requires training person a specific
personnel pistol technologist that are
doing the staining it requires a lab
space some of those things requires
monitoring by the histo technologist and
the other thing is doesn't support
tissue preservation or advanced
diagnosis and as you can see here this
process is prone to staining variation
so basically different technicians in
the same level and between labs so might
provide a different staining result
which makes it harder for a diagnosis
for different pathologists and today
growing number of machine learning
algorithms that use those can tissue
samples images as inputs so about let's
say two decades ago there has been a
substantial started substantial effort
to come up with alternative contrasting
method and there were basically two
schools of thought one of them is
rapid painting rapid painting basically
takes a tissue fresh tissue or a section
tissue and put it into some staining
chemical bath which for example might be
equity in orange or or using and then
image it with some sort of an
alternative microscopy technique for
example two-photon or secondary mourning
generation or UV surface excitation and
the other school of thought went with
completely label-free imaging and then
acquire multiple images at multiple
modality could be multi photon or high
harmonic generations
another very popular approach is remin
microscopy and also quantitative phase
microscopy more recently so all these
provide us with some contrast which can
be translated into diagnosis however
most professionals clinicians are not
trained with this kind of imaging
modalities therefore there needs to be
some sort of a bridge between those
methods and what clinicians are used to
look at because the training retraining
the expert and and also algorithms that
today are well trained with millions
maybe of images coming from standard
standardly stain is to chemically
stained tissues will also be very costly
and also there is no almost no data for
any other modality out there so the
solution would be why what's called
pseudo staining which was based on
taking basically the contrast that's
created by
them one of the methods that we describe
and do some approximation to the
intensity of the dye concentration at
that specific pixels a pixel or group of
pixels and it will require multiple
images or spectra or some sort of rapid
painting mechanisms that we also mention
before so here we demonstrated a deep
learning approach that is a completely
label free which is called we call it
virtual staining and it's using
basically a single auto fluorescence
image of the section tissue and it has
the potential to eliminate the
histological staining process and from a
single single auto fluorescence image to
create an image that's how a matching
image from a bright field microscope as
following the same process of the tissue
so for that we chose for the
autofluorescence wavelengths we chose
the duffy because it has a good
excitation a profile for many
constituents in the tissue so for the
training we use the again a generative
adversarial networks as Honda mentioned
a few minutes before which takes the
auto fluorescent image and and tries to
a full critic Network or a discriminator
and that balance between the networks
generates a high quality image that
matches the stained image that we had
seen in the ground true again it's also
very important to mention that we're
doing a multiple stage registration too
and we saw it's extremely important to
do this stage yeah
us to get the highest quality of images
between the result of the network and
the matching ground truth and sort of
preserving all the features of the
tissue in terms of training time it
theorized again depending on on the
number of data samples that we've had
some of it went all the way to two days
but again it was sort of it was trained
on a standard desktop machine and always
this is scaleable with higher
performance servers once this thing is
trained it can output an image that's
about the times if you calculate is
about 1.9 second per millimeter square
which stands in line with the scanning
speed of traditional microscopes or even
faster sly scanning microscopes so once
we trying to network here are some
examples of results first of all with
the standard H&E staining which is the
most basic staining with about 85% or so
of these things that are being used
today are H and E and the annotations
here that you see with the errors and
the stars were made by the pathologist
that we worked work with us on this
research showing some features that show
that were born for the diagnosis of this
tissue this was for the library gland
but we did it for other tissues as well
so what is extremely special about this
worm framework is this was the first
demonstration of special stain here is
an example of a Mason Shrike from
Stane offer for a lung tissue and again
till now there has been no demonstration
of any anything else other than heme
which is pretty simple to perform even
with pseudo staining techniques and the
other thing we've done here is what we
call the jones silver stain this is for
a kidney tissue and this is a basement
membrane stain that is used many times
in a diagnosis of diabetes this case is
there is a tumor on those tissues but we
still use the silver thing so another
the most important thing in here is to
behind beyond our analysis is a
deep-lying assessment which was done by
the pathologist
at the end of the day we gave those
images to pathologists and blindly
assign them either virtual or
histological stains and they had to
perform some diagnosis based on the
images that they have received and the
conclusion of this study which was again
performed by board-certified pathologist
that there was no major disorders or no
clinically significant difference in the
diagnosis in the virtual and
histological stain
and the other assessment that the
pathologist have done was what we called
staining efficacy and staining ethicacy
are same quality we asked them to give a
grade between one three and two
different size metric details that we
asked them hello and and the overall
staining quality and we were very happy
to learn that there was again no
preference if ik reference to either the
virtual or histochemical stain in fact
most apologists like the virtual stain
more than the histochemical stain one of
the interesting attributes of this net'
of this framework is that it's it's
standardized the staining if you look at
the top row this is a staining of a
liver tissue section and you see there
is some staining variation but the
network does not do this staining
variation it converges to some sort of a
common common color palette or
polarization panel of this tissue
section and it will be very helpful for
both clinician and machine learning
algorithms in terms of this staining
standardization another interesting
thing was that for example when we
looked at the sample that contains
Melanie and melanin basically absorbs
almost all the light of the illumination
where things that we use the Duffy and
so as we can see here on the last image
when Ezra tries to reconstruct that he
basically fought the loan in his part of
the background but when we added a low
resolution scan with another wavelengths
again everything is of the fluorescent
label free we were able to
reconstruct faithfully that melanine so
it is emerged and and this is one of the
ways for us to try to add more
information if necessary to those
virtual this virtual staining framer so
to summarize this is another example of
our neural network can create
interesting opportunity for microscopy
in this case we are it transforms a
label free image of a section into how
it would look into a stained version
using a standard microscope and an
filter set it's it's very compatible
with for low resource settings and it
supports to do smaller biopsies it can
do multiple stains on the same tissue
section it can do it can handle multiple
fixations such as frozen section and
paraffin fixation it can accommodate the
other modalities such as the
quantitative phase microscopy which is
we have demonstrated another effort and
it can enable a more advanced analysis
after we have done the virtual staining
because we're label free and then we can
just send it to more advanced analysis
so this concludes our talk thank you for
listening and we're looking forward to
getting some of your questions
Thanks our three speakers for were very
informative presentation so we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar so if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer in question box located at
the far left of your screen we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started
you
our first question actually we we've got
a quite a few recurring questions
concerning actually the concerns that
might arise when it comes to artifacts
but are might be induced by these deep
learning network so the question is
essentially can you explain the
different steps that you are taking to
ensure the integrity of the deep
learning output
so yeah that's a great question and we
frequently get this asked the the paper
that we published at the end of 2018 in
Nature Methods has actually a specific
sub section dedicated to artifact
analysis and in the manuscript and the
supplementary information we've given
various different methods analysis to
quantify artifacts by looking into
resolution by looking at cross-sections
of input-output grandfer by looking at
peeked a big separation of articles or
features within this specimen by
overlaying ground truth against the
network in fear insulting colors looking
for color artifacts by looking into
spatial frequency analysis spatial
frequencies of the input ground truth
and the output of the network and other
other tools that we've quantified to to
look at potential artifacts and to
verify that in need we're getting what
we what we would like to to match the
ground truth in fact in some cases even
surpassed some of the artifacts of the
ground with some of the limitations of
the grounds were that also surpassed and
I think Hong that gave some great
examples of this with some of the slides
that she that he shared today in terms
of depth of field enhancement in terms
of some of the artifacts that are
cleaned up so we've taken this very
rigorously and and I think our papers
have ample evidence of the fact that
what being feared is very nicely
conditional it's a generative adverse
one network but at the same time because
of how we train it is conditioning it to
in fear within the limits of the
physical system and the fact that the
input images are also coming from a
microscope that is imaging the same
sample with with some resolution not to
be enhanced it's helping us to say
we retain artifacts within a
well-conditioned limit in the case of
the virtual staining case which also
uses a generator generated virtual
network we've done similar analysis at
the network output to look into spatial
frequencies to look into resolution to
look into structural similarity index to
look into color distance of the
network's output with respect to the
bright field actually it's the
chemically stain samples and shown that
they're actually matching each other but
more than that we've given them to
board-certified pathologist for them to
look into stain quality for them to look
into diagnostic value of our images in
fact to the level where board-certified
pathologist a group of them could not
tell the difference between our images
in theirs especially for a specific
application like this like virtual
staining in the chemistry is that so
long G as a field the ground truth is
obviously what diagnosticians are
accustomed to seeing and that's why
we're confident that what we generate is
satisfying the needs of the application
and in that case the needs of the
pathology field as certified by these
diagnose stations and group of them was
there any other analysis tools that you
used that I didn't mention oh that's
scary clogging yeah yeah um so in
addition to that we also use non
addressed girl plugin as I talked in the
slide to calculate the potential
artifacts between the super resolved
image and the input image and we show
that the mismatch is lower us lower than
the mismatch between the ground truth
and input image so the artifact there is
very minimal so in fact a related
question that we sometimes get asked is
we're training use
grounds with images that have limited
depth of field sometimes that have
artifacts so how can you actually
surpass that that's actually a very
interesting question the input images
have extended depth of field because
they're captured by their captured by a
low of numerical aperture system by
definition they have a longer depth of
field so so we essentially generalize to
bring a larger depth of field into focus
with enhanced resolution compared to the
ground truth and that's actually
validated in our results by taking our
inference results comparing it to a high
na image and we claim some parts of our
images in network inference results show
features that are out of focus in the
ground truth to show that this is
physically the case we take the same
sample and image it with an axial
scanning high in a objective lens and
create an extended depth of field by for
example capturing 20 images with with a
half of micron or less than that axial
scanning to indeed show and validate
that the enhancement in the depth of
field is a physical property of the
input image which is enhanced in
resolution across a larger depth of
field so those are extended depth of
field images are also part of our
analysis part of these papers to show
the advantages of the network impedance
similar analysis also applies to
structural relation microscopy sim
results which depending on the
aberration depending on the sample
depending on the field of view sometimes
have certain aberrations through
construction artifacts appearing those
are also attacked by our network and we
have provided evidence of that in our
papers and in some of the movies that we
have as supplementary information to the
paper
thank you very much a few of our
listeners are asking how many images are
needed for training the deep network I
think so yeah it basically depends on
the application
for one application that I think was our
first paper deep learning microscopy we
trained with like 10,000 very small
patches 60 by 60 pixels and transforming
them into 150 150 pixels so basically
it's just one slide of the lung tissue
sections that we scan and use the N for
training and with that tissue with that
network model train from that tissue we
basically were able to infer many other
types of tissues and and also a
resolution a test target so and got the
highest using higher resolution
enhancement as we've demonstrated for
for just the lung tissue section in
other cases we might need more data
for example for the virtual staining
it's one case we had the scan about six
seven
tissue sections
to get that sort of a standardized stain
and but and that thing again kind of
their eyes according to through your
application but I would say that in
general you need much less samples than
you would need for classification
frameworks because here we're basically
trying to predict the pixel value or a
group of pixels from another group of
pixels so we have in each slide we
already have millions of those so it's
in some senses it's slightly easier task
and we need overall less data
thank you we have one question from the
audience here asking if these deep
learning models are available to the
research community yes that's a great
question we have made some of our models
publicly available these are also
mentioned in the code availability parts
of our manuscripts that we have got also
some sample images there some test
images some comparison ground truth
images for them to play around with our
models later this year if we have some
resources and time we would like to also
open up some of our databases for
research community to also work on their
own models their own model development
testing training processes so we're all
so eager to kind of combine some of the
work that we've done into a single
portal to share some of our rural images
because these are quite exciting
valuable results that we'd like to have
other people repeat expand and using
their own applications
thank you so it looks like we have time
for maybe one more question so maybe
I'll take that opportunity to ask you
guys is there any limit to these
approaches I mean we have seen cross
fidelity transformations we have seen
application to astrology and pathology I
mean what else
so this is a great question I think
yerin on death should end the ultimate
limit for these frameworks is signal to
noise ratio so and that's actually also
a strength and also a weakness Oh Chris
framework in the sense that as the noise
statistics change you will have to
retrain which means as for example your
microscope changes it's a good idea if
your type of sample changes the good
idea to up maybe take your model and
train it with the combination of the new
types of samples new types of
microscopes that you have but ultimately
on the deep neural net is learning
spatial spectral features of objects
types of objects to generalize those
features that are learned inherent to
the network - in fear enhanced images
while doing so it rejects it learns and
reject noise so it's ultimate limit by
Sims noise ratio in fact all micron
cream modalities regardless of how they
work whether they claim to beat
diffraction limit whether they claim to
match diffraction limit or any others
their capability or what they claim and
how successful they are with their
claims is fundamental to the single
noise ratio this applies to that this
applies to calm visit like storm any any
other my classical model in this regard
we're on the same ballpark its snr limit
as a result if you want to jump from
optical microscopy to electron
microscopy the noise that we have in an
optical microscope and the spatial
features that are of interest is
electron microscopy won't let you jump
faithfully
by then we looked into those kinds of
transformations from optics direct from
microscopy but but we're altima to
limited with what you can assume at the
noise level and what what noise uh gives
us
however it's certainly possible to have
roughly and prickly I can say two to
threefold increase in each direction for
example for resolution enhancer the same
applies for example for virtual staining
if your autofluorescence images go
weaker and weaker for certain sub sub
tissue sub cellular components then it
won't work for us to stain virtually
that's where maybe we should switch to
another band of florence's where it's
better snr or maybe ultimately switched
to another contrast mechanism like for
example quantitative phase imaging GPI
holography to generate those labeled
free image and then switch to a virtual
staining in fact the recent work we've
done that we've used another contrast
mechanism like quantized phase imaging
to do virtual staining it has certain
advantages and disadvantages compared to
other fluorescence but these are
essentially a dark disposal as weapons
so to speak that we can utilize to
handle SNR challenges contrast
challenges artifacts that different
contrasts new chasms have to be to get
them to do whatever we want the neural
net to do it sometimes also outside the
physical world in terms of how we are
thinking it can do transformations that
are not possible with standard forward
models and that's actually a very
powerful aspect of the neural nets and
how they can help us with image
transformations one great example of
this actually is between both the
fluorescence and bright field imaging
with the virtual staining Apple to
Orange transformation there is no
physical model that you can faithfully
construct between it to a similar
conclusion also applies between
hagh Rafi holographic image contrast and
bright field one of them is a single
frequency single color the other one is
actually a white light type of an
imaging system so these are very
exciting aspects and ultimately in
different modalities different contrast
mechanisms will enjoy what deep neural
Nets can offer to enhance our experience
of microscopic images that are going to
be feeding into professionals diagnosed
patients for their own use in different
settings thank you before we conclude I
would like to thank our speakers
professor Erskine professor version and
dr. Wong and I would like to ask you if
you have any final comments for audience
so one final comment that I would like
to add is let's say we have a model that
we train with our microscopes
but and we already experimented with
data that was generated from other
microscopes and use the concept of
transfer learning basically either
adding one more layer to the deep
network or do some sort of a soft
restart of the training of the network
from the wasted facility trained list
but very small amount of data and and
then we were able basically to
generalize to the new data to the new
tasks that with that to enhance and so
far from some of the examples that we
have done for what might not be again
with a very limited number of images
thank you again professor reading on
askin professor yair reversing and
graduate student Hong Kong for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
or sponsor like a micro systems for
underwriting to this educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
didn't have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speaker be as a
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand lab routes will alert
you through email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues we may
have missed to this live event until
next time goodbye